ANKUR KOTWAL: The
Camera2 API in Android L
gives you immense
control of the camera.
I'm Ankur Kotwal, a
developer advocate at Google,
and I'd like to show you
how amazing these APIs are.
But first, let's look at
the Kit Kat camera API.
It really was designed for the
straightforward point and shoot
camera apps, and
because of this,
there are limited ways to
access streaming image data.
The API also doesn't support any
manual capture control methods.
In order to overcome
these limitations
and give developers
the capability
to build awesome
camera apps, we've
introduced a completely
new set of APIs
under the
Android.hardware.Camera2
package.
Let's take a look.
These new APIs are
designed as a pipeline,
instead of a one way stream.
It is now possible to
preconfigure output surfaces
and attach them to the camera.
Each surface can
be a destination
for a stream of image buffers,
and you can pass a request
through the capture session.
Each request will be converted
into one result object,
and the destination surface will
be filled with image buffers.
It is possible to pass multiple
requests simultaneously,
and these requests will be
processed asynchronously.
Let's look at what it takes
to build a simple camera
app using these new APIs.
First, you need to
detect camera hardware.
You can do so by enumerating the
existing cameras on a device,
and get the detailed
information off the camera
by using the
CameraManager service.
You can then use a camera by
calling the open camera method
with an ID and a callback list.
When a device is ready,
the onOpened method
is invoked with a
camera device instance.
This instant is a representation
of a single camera.
Before submitting
requests, you need
to define a set of
buffer output targets
and connect them to
the camera device.
This is done by initiating
the camera capture session.
For example, you can use
TextureView for previewing,
MediaRecorder for
recording a video,
or the RenderScriptAllocation
for YUV processing.
When you create a surface,
the size of the surface
is important.
The camera device only supports
a certain type of size,
and therefore you must set the
valid size for each surface.
First, we get the available
stream configurations
that the camera supports by
the scalar stream configuration
map.
The size should be
one of the results
from the getOutputSizes method.
For this example, we're just
going to grab the first one,
but in a real
world scenario, you
may want to look
through this array
and pick the appropriate size.
After creating the
necessary surface,
you can call the
createCaptureSession method.
Be patient, as creating
a session can require
several hundred milliseconds.
Once the session is ready, you
can deal with the requests.
Based on your needs, you
can create a request builder
by using one of the
pre-defined templates.
Then you can build
the capture request
by calling the build
method in the build up.
Here, TEMPLATE_PREVIEW is
used for the preview request,
and TEMPLATE_STILL_CAPTURE
is used for the JPEG capture
request.
So now, you have both a
session and a request,
and there are two options
to submit requests.
Capture is to capture one image
using a given capture request.
On the other hand,
setRepeatingRequest
is for capturing
images continuously
by using a given request again
and again until you explicitly
stop it.
Both capture and
setRepeatingRequests
have overloads that take a
list of capture requests.
CaptureBurst for capture,
and setRepeatingBurst
for set repeating requests.
However, before submitting
the capture request,
you might need to
adjust the camera
settings as per your needs.
It is possible to modify any
properties of the builder
before building a request.
These can be things like
white balance mode, effects,
and even flash settings.
There are some
really great effects
that you can apply, like
negatives, and sepia,
and solarize, and more.
You can interact with exposure
and focus settings precisely
using CONTROL_AF_TRIGGER and
CONTROL_AE_PRECAPTURE_TRIGGER.
Be careful though.
If you forget to
set focus properly,
you can end up with an image
that's a little bit blurry.
Whenever you submit
requests, you
can pass a capture
listener callback
to keep track of
capture progress.
For example, you can
use onCaptureStarted
for playing a shutter sound
or for playing a capture
animation.
And after a capture
request is processed,
onCaptureCompleted will be
called with a total capture
request result instance.
At this moment,
TotalCaptureResult
contains the final configuration
of the capture process,
and the destination
surfaces will soon
be sent the final captured data.
You can access the output
image through the surface,
and then it's up to you
on how to use that image.
In a basic camera app, you
could get the bytes buffer
of the image from
the image reader,
and stored it on to the SD card.
So this is the new Camera2 API.
It is designed as a very
flexible and unified pipeline
for all camera related
tasks, and it also
increases the ability
of applications
to control the camera subsystem.
You can discover more
details about the Camera2 API
and useful samples at
developer.Android.com
Be sure to check out
the Android Developer
Preview for more new APIs.
Thank you.